The engine has to burn
for about fifteen seconds.
The computer is off.
And three astronauts are trying
to steer a damaged spacecraft
back to Earth.
Jim Lovell looks out the
window to keep the planet
in view.
The men have been awake
too long, the cabin is
cold,
and every remaining bit of
power matters.
Somewhere on board is a
small, old-fashioned answer to
one urgent question:
when do we shut the
engine off? The answer is
a wristwatch.
A mechanical chronograph.
Jack Swigert has one on
his wrist, and the Science
Museum credits his watch with
timing crucial engine firings
during Apollo 13.
How did a watch end
up with a job on
a trip to the Moon?
And why would NASA trust
it when the spacecraft itself
was in trouble?
In an Apollo photograph,
almost everything looks
specially built for space.
The suit. The helmet.
The spacecraft behind it.
Then there is the watch:
a dial, a couple of
buttons,
and a strap over the
sleeve.
is an Omega Speedmaster.
A chronograph is a stopwatch
you can wear.
Press one button and a
hand starts counting seconds.
Press it again and it
stops.
That matters when a task
must last a precise number
of seconds:
an experiment,
a maneuver, a stretch outside
the spacecraft.
The Speedmaster does not need
the ship's electricity to do
that job.
You wind it by hand.
The watch is not smarter
than the spacecraft.
It has one simple advantage:
it keeps doing its job
when another system has to
be switched off.
That was useful long before
Apollo 13.
But first the watch had
to persuade NASA that it
belonged there at all.
Imagine buying a watch and
asking the salesperson a few
questions.
Will it survive water?
A hard knock?
Magnetism?
Now add violent acceleration and
temperatures that would make an
ordinary day feel very far
away.
That was the sort of
list NASA brought to its
search for a crew chronograph.
NASA tested watches for
precision and reliability.
The Speedmaster made the cut
and was qualified for crewed
spaceflight in 1965.
By Apollo,
it was mission equipment rather
than a lucky personal accessory.
The choice had a quiet
logic.
A watch could travel with
an astronaut,
work inside or outside,
and measure an interval without
asking the spacecraft for power.
You can call that redundancy.
In the middle of a
crisis, it feels more like
having one extra chance.
When Apollo 11 landed on
the Moon,
Neil Armstrong faced a strange
choice:
take his Speedmaster outside, or
leave it in the lunar
module.
He left it inside.
The module's timer had caused
trouble, and a watch could
serve as a backup while
Buzz Aldrin took his own
onto the surface.
That is how the astronauts
later remembered the decision.
The man to step onto
the Moon left his watch
indoors.
The famous photograph was less
important than having a way
to keep time inside the
lander.
The Speedmaster earned its
nickname on the Moon.
The next chapter would show
a different side of it.
A mission that never reached
the lunar surface would need
every backup it had.
Apollo 13 had a landing
site and a crew of
three.
Jim Lovell was the commander.
Fred Haise was the lunar
module pilot.
Jack Swigert joined at the
last minute, replacing Ken
Mattingly after a measles scare.
Swigert wore a Speedmaster.
His flight watch is now
in the Smithsonian collection.
It was a small part
of the equipment on board
and, at first,
hardly the most exciting thing
to watch.
For nearly two days, the
flight was routine enough that
a controller in Houston joked
they were bored.
Then the crew finished a
television broadcast.
Nine minutes later, an oxygen
tank exploded.
A bang shook the spacecraft.
Alarms followed.
Within hours, the Moon landing
was gone.
The new mission was simpler
to say and much harder
to do:
bring all three men home.
The command module lost its
normal supply of electricity,
light and water.
Imagine your house suddenly
losing all three,
then remember that this house
is moving through space.
crew moved into the lunar
module,
a machine built to carry
two people down to the
Moon and back.
Now it had to keep
three people alive long enough
to return to Earth.
At Mission Control,
teams wrote and tested new
procedures
while the astronauts dealt with
a cold cabin, dwindling water
and an air system that
needed an improvised fix.
The watch cannot clean the
air or tell Houston where
the spacecraft is.
But the rescue is made
of hundreds of small jobs.
Some require a room full
of engineers.
Others require someone to count
seconds accurately while the
engines run.
First, the crew had to
get back onto a path
around the Moon and toward
Earth.
They fired the lunar module's
engine.
Later, after swinging past the
far side, they fired it
again to shorten the journey
and change where they would
land.
Each maneuver bought them a
better chance.
But they still had to
arrive at Earth at the
right angle.
Too shallow and the craft
could skip away.
Too steep and reentry would
become dangerous. Their
remaining power and water were
too precious to use the
lunar module's computer for
every task.
For one final short correction,
NASA had another plan.
The men would aim by
looking at Earth and the
Sun through the windows,
fire the engine by hand,
and stop it at the
right second.
Earth was still about 175,000
miles away.
The engine starts.
Lovell keeps the spacecraft
lined up. Swigert has the
seconds.
A few moments later,
the engine stops.
The firing lasts 14.8 seconds,
and NASA says it makes
the correction they needed.
It is the kind of
scene that sounds invented.
A spacecraft is trying to
return from the Moon,
and one of the useful
tools is a watch that
needs no battery from the
ship.
But that is why NASA
had tested it and sent
it in the first place.
Houston had worked out the
maneuver.
The crew still had to
do it, in a damaged,
freezing spacecraft, without the
computer they would normally
have used for the timing.
This is where a backup
stops sounding boring.
The story is sometimes condensed
into one line: a watch
saved Apollo 13.
It is catchy.
It also misses the people
who made the rescue possible.
The watch could measure an
interval. It could not calculate
the course, hold the spacecraft
steady
or make the engine fire.
That was the work of
the crew and the teams
in Houston.
A good backup does not
replace them. It gives them
one more dependable tool when
the normal plan has failed.
And the most surprising part
is that the watch had
been there all along.
It did not arrive as
a rescue device.
It was standard equipment,
chosen years before anyone knew
what would happen to this
crew.
Apollo 13 never landed on
the Moon.
But Lovell, Haise and Swigert
came home.
NASA later called it a
successful failure:
the landing failed;
the rescue succeeded.
The Speedmaster already had its
Moon story.
Armstrong had left his inside
the lander to back up
a troublesome timer;
Aldrin took his onto the
surface.
Apollo 13 gave the watch
a different kind of moment.
Nothing glamorous. Just seconds
that mattered when the
spacecraft's systems could not
do every job.
That is why NASA trusted
a wristwatch in space.
It had been tested.
The crew knew how to
use it. And it could
keep counting when they needed
to save the spacecraft's power
for the journey home.
The most famous watch in
space did not have to
be a hero.
It only had to be
ready.